the jurgen experience you want to talk
about little people do you want to talk
about the house
elves which ones the machine house oh
okay because i want to talk to you about
it because i've been doing some research
about this
research yeah what kind of research
taking drugs
i would never take drugs oh drugs you
know if someone's on drugs they say
what's wrong with him is he on drugs
is he a drug addict you would never want
crazy people only crazy people
yeah drugs yeah so do you think you've
done more to popularize dmt than anybody
else
do you think that these elves are real i
don't know if
uh real is the right word the the
question is
we look at consciousness and we look at
uh
like an intelligent
entity as being in a physical
carbon-based form
that's in front of you that you can
shake hands with or give a hug to
right when you experience what happens
when you take dimethyltryptamine
you throw all that out the window
because
the environment itself is not
it's it's it's there's it's not defined
it's fluid meaning that it's changing
constantly
but yet it seems far more vivid
and far more real right than this life
right now
and there are these things that are
there
and they communicate with you and they
seem to be really communicating with you
and they seem to also know you
know all of your [ __ ] and be able to
see right through yes
but they don't seem to be you they seem
to be something else
right that's all we know right but i'm
asking you what you think but that's
what i think
that's all we know there's no you can't
like you could say that's a well of
souls
that's what happens when you die that's
the afterlife that's a parallel
dimension
these are aliens it's how they can
communicate with us they're they're
non-physical life forms that exist
in these realms of light we don't know
it's just
you're just guessing right well i've
been talking to people
and i've been told the theory that we
are 3d beings but they're 40 beings
so that we're 3d projections of 40
beings
so when you're taking you're breaking
the veil you are perceiving the 4d space
maybe but that's all you could ever say
it's really just a maybe you know when
everybody said when
people say i know what that is i am
communicating with the afterlife
or i know what that is these are the
real aliens this is what happens when
you're sleeping
and people have these alien abduction
experiences what they really are having
is
an endogenous dmt dump because your
brain does produce dmt right
um but new research is being is showing
that it's not just the brain
that produces dmt that it's it's they
used to think it was the pineal gland
but now they think literally the whole
brain is producing it and the liver and
the lungs so it's it's
part of the human body it's something
that the human body makes they've been
able to isolate it in specific organs
but they think this really bizarre super
potent
psychedelic compound is everywhere and
they also think it's responsible for
dreaming they think
there's an amount of it that comes out
while you're sleeping while you're in
heavy rem sleep
this is speculative they're trying to
but the thing is there's parallels
right one of the parallels to these
psychedelic states
and dreams is that they're very
difficult to recall
they like right you wake up and it's the
most vivid you come out of the
experience right it's the most vivid
thing that you've ever experienced
in your life and then moments later
you're like i don't remember what
happened
it's just like a dream so you've never
had because everyone who takes it talks
about the spirit molecule right how much
it affects their understanding of
reality so on and so forth you've never
had lingering effects
from the dmt experience crossover into
meat space
you mean like tripping for no reason or
just seeing
the way i've been told is that like if
you're on a highway right
and there's all these billboards you
don't notice what those billboards are
right but let's suppose you're in a
highway another country and
you don't understand what those
billboards are if you want if you want
to because they're another language
after you take it you are able to see
those signs
and perceive them and read them so that
things in real life that you would
previously been oblivious to
you now pick up on connections that you
previously couldn't
well i guess you could say that any time
you have a paradigm
shifting moment in your life where you
could have this from just from a
near-death experience or the loss of a
loved one where you're forced to
re-evaluate everything and look at
things through fresh
fresh eyes that anything like that
is going to force you anything that's
just so titanically bizarre
and ultimately incredibly different than
your average day on this earth this
thing that changes you
it's going to force you to take things
in i would look at it that way
more than i would look at it like all of
a sudden you can like see these
billboards in another country and
recognize these patterns
you're just probably just being more
aware marijuana does that for me more
than anything okay
you know especially edible marijuana
edible marijuana for me
is like one of the the
most reality highlighting
experiences because it makes me think
about the buildings like this is
i just take these [ __ ] things for
granted yeah yeah there's a 64-story
thing in front of me and there's
these human catacombs and people are
shedding into these tubes
and they go down through the water and
it's there's pipes everywhere with
human [ __ ] and then there's electricity
pumping through everything and
everyone's got a a tv or a playstation
running and
we're all just juiced into this machine
and yeah the matrix yeah
listen i think of people as human
batteries all the time
i really do i think of people as
as consuming
currency producing batteries
like that's what we're consuming things
taking things
in and then we're also through our work
all day long so many people just doing
something they hate to do just to create
currency
and then to add to the system and to
purchase more things
and to just see them sitting in front of
their machine sitting for the machine
and they go home sitting in front of the
tv
sitting in front of the screen on their
car and we're just we're constantly in
this state
of of of consuming and producing
consuming and producing
and then adding to this weird techno
society that we live in okay let me
that's all from weed okay but let me ask
you another question
okay let's suppose i drew in a piece of
paper i drew you
and i drew me and i drew a house right
and i said what does what correspond to
and you'd point to that you'd say that's
me and you point to that you say that's
malice
that house has no correspondence in 3d
space it's a theoretical house
right okay what if some of these people
that you're talking about
don't exist in the 4d space what if they
are 3d representations that don't have a
representation in 4d space just like
that 2d house i just drew
doesn't really exist okay so what if
they're like
what what is that npcs yeah what if
they're literally don't
have a higher higher form of existence
isn't that like your ego [ __ ] with
you though
well that's why i'm asking you because
apparently when people do a lot of dmt
they
they see things like this oh do they
yeah that's what i've heard
um yeah one i've met people that see
things on dmt that were very ego driven
like uh i knew a guy who had a crazy dmt
trip and he felt like he had a team
that was working for him in this other
dimension
and they were all about him and they're
helping him and they're all together
with him
and that like you know his life he has
destiny in his life and he has to
fulfill his destiny and they're working
to fulfill i'm like this is like some
weird
ego driven idea of what's happening in
this space
that he's like sort of he's forcing
whatever that experience was to fit this
mold
of what he he thinks of himself and by
the way
it wasn't very accomplished at the time
right so
think of thinks of this as like it's you
know delusions of grandeur of course
i know well yeah
but this is i think a kind of uh
some sort of a reconciliation of that
like he's sort of
trying to figure out why it's not
happening the way he wants it to happen
and what is what is wrong
but yet also tripping and seeing these
entities and
and saying oh they're all with me
they're going to help me they're they're
working with me
on all of my plans and this is this is
all my team and another li it was
very strange so i never felt like that
at all
i've i've felt every time i've done it
it's like here's all your [ __ ] oh
yeah
look at you loser like it like it's a
highlight
it's never like you're so great and
we're so honored to be talking to you
joe rogan it's like dude get over
yourself no you ain't [ __ ]
yeah but i thought that there are as
it's that's there are some people
who basically become chiropractors of
reality
so if he's like you're going to help me
achieve my goals and you're behind me
that's nonsense
yeah but if he's there to help them
achieve their goals
that's a whole very different
perspective yeah sure so like that kind
of thing where like
just awesome things happen to you not
what you would want
but you're basically an agent of
bringing about positivity
and kindness in the world hmm yeah
well i think the more you can do
good things right the more you can be an
agent of kindness and positivity
the the more you're going to literally
spread out the fingers and
branches of love right and if you do
do that and then you do have psychedelic
experiences
i would imagine if you've made a
positive shift like that
your your experience would be much more
positive when you go into that dimension
right yeah catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience